out with more he had a huge victory in
the great state of Florida
Florida Senator Marco Rubio you know I
don't know Senator nearly 20 percent of
the vote
um you know you could have done a lot
better I'm really
um I I think he let the party down
well we tried our best we were out
raised two to one and we won Florida by
more than Schumer one New York and a
bunch of other people won liberal states
like Illinois and things of that nature
but we're look we're very proud of the
race people worked very hard and I think
at the end of the day with the shows use
a couple things you talked about one of
them and that is the changes that we're
seeing in Florida but the changes in
Florida aren't just people moving here
that's certainly true people are moving
here because they want to get away from
this lunacy in other parts of the
country but the other change it's what's
happening to people that traditionally
are not identified with the Republican
Party particularly working class and
small business owning Hispanics Hispanic
families who have common sense who don't
want schools indoctrinating their kids
who perhaps have either firsthand or
family experience with socialism and
leftism and don't want any part of it in
this country and and who frankly you
know want to live in a society that's
governed by Leaders with common sense
you're not going to convince them that
we should care more about allowing
illegal immigrants in the U.N climate
conference that they're having this week
criminals running straight through the
streets you put those things ahead of
them and their interests are going to
punish you at The Ballot Box that's what
they did to Democrats here in Florida
that's what I wish we'd be seeing in
other parts of the country unfortunately
there's multiple reasons why that's not
happening and and the ultimate price
will be paid by our country and I
actually think Sean all of this is going
to make the Democrats even more radical
you already see Biden saying he's not
going to change anything they think this
is an affirmation they think that what's
happened over the last few days because
they didn't get wiped out is going is
licensed for them to go out and be
crazier than they've ever been so we
have a big fight ahead of us
irrespective of how these seats turn out
you know when you look at the number 850
people moving into Florida on a daily
basis day after day after day that is an
astronomical figure
Senator and the only problem is there's
a little damage left in the wake of that
because the people that are leaving New
York New Jersey Pennsylvania and they're
going they tend to go to the east coast
of Florida and then you've got the
Midwest and that's Wisconsin Michigan
Illinois Indiana they seem to go to the
west coast of Florida I've been on both
coasts of Florida and the problem is
that makes those States harder for
Republicans to win I think it's having
an impact on the rest of the country do
you see that
it is look that's a factor I don't know
if the numbers are there yet for it but
I'm sure it's a you know every every
Republican voter that moves to Florida
is great for us it obviously is taking a
voter away from somewhere else but I
think we also have to understand
something I mean literally every
everything in our society and culture is
aligned against Republicans it's America
Republicans went anywhere every
virtually every major television and
media Outlet in America is against us
all the celebrities all the movie actors
I mean you name it it's just constant
the tech companies the list goes now
major American corporations so it's
amazing that Republicans are even
competitive much less winning these
seats and look I think we're going to
win the house we still have a real
chance we're going to win Nevada I think
Arizona I don't know it's an
embarrassment I honestly think like you
guys are reporting and I don't have
anything against the state Arizona great
people but it seems like you guys are
reporting on some third world country
that's having one of these elections
where every day they're finding new
boxes here new votes there I don't
understand how this is possible in the
21st Century Florida had a lot more
votes had every vote tabulary we knew
how many people had voted by 705 805 and
they had they were already reporting
results in Miami-Dade County which has
you know almost a million voters were
cast here by 704 they had already posted
all the early votes because they had set
it up and I just don't get it I don't
understand it
yeah I it's it's wrong it's unfair to
the people in those States but it's also
unfair to the people in the rest of the
country Senator this was a massive uh
win uh congratulations to you and to the
governor and uh uh job well done thank
you for taking time for being with us
thanks for creating a safe haven for
people that like Freedom hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else